big changes ahead coveted restrictions
will loosen right here in clark county
starting tomorrow
good afternoon and thank you so much for
joining us here at 4 30 i'm christian
cosadas i'm kirstjen joyce that means
indoor capacity will increase to 80
percent
social distancing goes down to 3 feet
hector
shows us how one business in las vegas
art district
is preparing
when clark county takes over
restrictions tomorrow restaurants will
be able to see parties of up to 12
people per table take a look right now
we are outside
seoul belly barbecue here in the arts
district we're about to witness a
ceremonial
lighting of the smoker this is one of
two smokers
joining us we have chef bruce coleman to
talk to us about
all right so what was that so these uh
smokers were made in mill
by a company called mill scale in
lockhart texas these beautiful offset
they used to be propane tanks
thousand gallon and we have to burn them
off for about five days to kind of get
rid of the metallic flav you know taste
you guys are getting ready to open with
eighty percent capacity when are you
guys opening
uh within a couple weeks hopefully it's
an exciting time in the arts district an
area that's seeing a lot of a lot of
redevelopment oh absolutely and it's
great to be sandwiched between these two
awesome microbreweries
just curious what was here before this
used to be a
an amco auto shop so it's pretty you
know you think also about barbecue right
barbecue and beer
auto shops a lot of barbecue places in
the south they serve barbecue
in gas stations awesome thanks for
having us so that's what's going on here
in the arts district hector mejia
reporting
8 news now